six times Grand Slam single champion
Boris Beckett
leftie
thank you
it's like the Wimbledon missus almost
almost good Apple said thank you for
having me it's great to have you on the
show thank you so much for being uh
let's talk about Djokovic you're his
trainer today would would Boris Becker
at his peach be able to beat today's
Djokovic well under his payrolls I can
attend to the honest truth but let's say
on clay I would have no chance on
hardcore difficult on grass I like to
play him what will happen then well
let's say I like my chance obviously
he's a current Roblin champion he's the
world number one so you know on the
other server says his return of you know
against myself would have been too good
but on grass you need to do a few more
things than just return and I feel like
I have a pretty good grass court game
you know back in the day up now so on
grass court it's a 50/50 match well what
can you teach him well when he called me
about fifteen months ago and I was very
humbled that you know the world's number
two called me to to get some advice and
possibly you know to have his tennis
game and I just was my question how can
I help you well let's let's come to
Monte Carlo meet for the weekend we had
a wonderful chat about tennis about the
the mental aspect of it you know
obviously having been on center court
many times winning and losing it's just
certain experiences you go through you
just don't learn by the book I taught a
fine
I'll well I think I'm um very German at
the way you know he's a he's very
emotional and very emotional man I was
civil happiness but some of the you know
I can't deny my German heritage meaning
I'm very punctual I'm very you know much
into work and just in having a goal and
his getcha and everything and I think
that that's another element he was
looking for but the fact that that the
fact that the the the other great player
at at the moment Roger Federer is
trained by your old rival Stephanie body
is that is that an extra motivation for
you what was quite odd to being a woman
file this year and you have a chalk of a
Trevor and understand he was at
Becca you know you can't you throw away
yeah but you know he's easy to play of
most respectful you know it was my
toughest rival but we always left the
business on the court we were never real
enemies of the court we liked each other
you know we really didn't go for dinner
with each other but we know we had
respect but it's odd to see to see my
toughest rival now coaching you know I
was toughest opponent on the call and
and is it
I didn't you let's let's let's state the
fact you what you want most of your
matches with with a bag and didn't you
well unfortunately the three women
finals are played I lost two but but
thanks for talking about the others yes
right yes the one you can't conquer it's
not yeah yeah you mentioned emotions the
psyche and you being quite quite an
emotional player but but you weren't
emotional in the same way that as as an
example take McEnroe he was it was
emotional indifferent he was more angry
well first of all we are human beings
that become tennis bliss and naturally
we have emotions and everybody has
different way of dealing with them in a
some player becomes become aggressive
against the other player against he
umpire and John McEnroe was a very good
example of that I was um I became
emotional against myself you know when I
was missing a shot or two you know their
chances I would scream or break the
racket but it was usually against me not
against others um but in the court you
could you could have these well I'd like
to keep my emotions in check off the
coat I mean either wise I beat up too
many people that would be so good for me
so I'd like to keep emotion in check is
but what could you say what kind of
words would you be impersonal in German
or English what is that is that a family
friendly program I don't know what type
of language was that happy Germans in
free and finding stories that when I
started playing I was very young I was
in 1617 and one of my first opponents
you know was John McEnroe and in the
very first match we played he came over
to change over and it was before the
courts were Mac miked up and all those
fines and players have to be so pc these
days what
back in the daily warned and my English
was limited but some of the words he
told me um really expanded my Dictionary
of the English language and I didn't
understand what they meant but they sure
sounded very bad women asked my coach
what it all meant that ah so ever since
I've been hanging out with McEnroe my
English improved tremendously sir
today I today you're a poker fan right
you play another poker I I have to let
my emotions go some where and somehow
and I love poker but how can you be an
emotional poker player III thought the
whole point with poker was not showing
emotions well not everybody can and
that's why you have some players with a
poker face and others the doughnut the
trick is to to you know beat your inner
demons and just give the other player
maybe a wrong emotions you know it's
called bluffing so it's all dealing you
know with yourself and others and and in
a poke are you playing against eight
other players on the table and it since
you know I'm little older I don't want
to run anymore after bought them and I
still think I'm 25 so I have to I'm
happily at night on a poker table yeah
so what would your poker face look like
anybody hot laughs if I thought I would
like to control the laughs therefore you
think I have a good hand no I think it's
really funny what you can do you know
these younger guys they have the hoodie
on and they have a hat on and the
glasses and I think it's a sign of
weakness if you have to cover your face
I think it's a sign of strength if you
can look at look at somebody into school
engage
exactly we have a good poker face too by
the way thank you yes you will see a lot
of that from now good let's go back to
to when you when you became world famous
a world famous player and it really went
from one day to another because he was
17 you won Wimbledon and the amazing
thing was that the air after you want it
again
who were you at that time I mean that
was a very good question I was a young
kid from West Germany in those days you
know we still had at the wall and you
know still at the border and probably
the youth what innocence of youth
protected me because I was too young to
understand that I was too young to
remember than 17 no but I just did it
and I ain't no obviously at the time I
was you know winning the first couple
rounds in the second week in
quarterfinal semifinal and in those days
we didn't have social media so you
couldn't always read it the next day how
great you are or how terrible you are
you just you know went went with the
flow and I had a nice team of protecting
me from from the outside world in the
media and I was just I thought that you
know you're supposed to play like that
on one business in the cold little did I
know that it changed my life
dramatically did did you what did you
feel like a child or a grown-up
well I started as a child and I became a
man very very quickly very quickly
exchanged my life yeah I have two
birthdays one is November the 22nd and
the other one is two lighter seventh
don't ask me that yet oh you became he
became a national hero in Germany I'm
probably also the most famous German in
in the world at the time is it is it
possible for you to make us understand
that pressure the pressure that was on
your shoulders
what difficult to to you know explained
it properly you know just a couple of
words but it was quite shocking at the
time because obviously I was a kid I was
a teenager and I was all you know
questions about politics and economics
and the confidence 17 years old I had
all the solutions for the world's
problems you know at 17 and 18 and I'm
still quoted some thirty years later
about somebody but you said two years
ago
such as exactly 30 years ago but in
overnight you just you know become an
assemble for what that's the question
because I didn't want to be a symbol I
didn't want to be a legend I felt like
legends are dead but I was very much
alive I wanted to if I was still writing
my own you know life history until today
so you know I'm very very fortunate and
blessed that I have gained so much you
know fame and fortune through that by
the other side is quite difficult
because you you you're judged only by
did one button a title obviously is
still a normal guy you know with the ups
and downs and and everything has been
very different especially Germany and
one of those sides were where that you
you were when you were supposed to sort
of rest on your laurels
the whole world got to know because it
was only a front page in the world do
you add a legitimate child how did you
get to know it what that you had a child
that you didn't know well um you know
there were many stories about it I'm a
proud father of four children
unfortunately only one daughter and
you're talking about Anna
she's a wonderful teenager now and she's
doing extremely well now in hindsight
I'm very happy things happened the way
they did obviously at the time and I was
married so that was really unfortunate
and my the first marriage went without
the drain but again with so much smarter
and so much mature now that I see it
with her with her in a smile in my face
and I'm happy the way things went well
see what's your relationship with your
daughter today well we live in the same
town she has a great mother she's very
good in school and as as much as I can
sue I do but you know she's a busy busy
you know teenager you know doing her
things and I'm busy as well but we
consider ourselves a beautiful patchwork
family so it's got kind of it became a
blessing after all it became a blessing
and at the time it was been a big big
shock for everybody involved but you
know we were we you know we've grown up
with it we spoke many times about it and
now
we have had the right to live their life
so as my daughter as you say a patchwork
patchwork family you have you have your
two boys in in Miami right well they
grown up now you know my old one or all
the one is 20 so he finished his calls
in my I mean I moved back in with me I'm
in London and have a 15 year old it
lives with my first wife in Miami and
I'm happily married again for the last
five years and we have a four yard and
little Amadeus
so we're interesting breakfast table
this morning were my 20 old and my fall
were together and it's it's a sight to
be seen yeah well you know all one has a
big beard now it looks cool is into
music and then ft is 40 old just still
in happy somewhat so it's a it's
interesting a conversation we have do
you do you see the old stars sometimes
in these this veteran company veteran
the you know you did feel what do you
call it whet veteran games well I don't
like the name it trim but you're right
and they call it seniors - I hate it
either why does your name Archer call it
the mature guys guys in your best age
all of the seniors um but you're
absolutely right there is a very
successful tour
I don't think Stephin plays much on it
anymore and I played for a couple years
but then I went into commentating and I
want to become a television you know
analyst and all that that's a lot easier
these days then playing yes people have
an image of me this powerful serve and
its timing all around oh well watch old
videos watch old DVDs but I won't do it
anymore so how is your service my serve
well I've broken my wrist last week of
its attempting you know to play tennis a
little bit and work with Djokovic in a
gym it's not happening at the moment
we're brace you know the last couple
days but I didn't want to be impolite
and showing you my brace but it's like
give me my left hand so you broke that
that's why we shave there you go yes yes
usually I do a bit too right because you
are trying to pay attendance again
there you go I should do it
can I tell you yeah we're having a few
other guests on and all of them one of
them is Bryan Ferry you know him right
oh he's a he's a i'll call him a friend
he's a wonderful man I love his music
and I'm excited to see him here
you seem sir thank you so much thank you
it's Becky please welcome
Kaplan around